I wouldn't say this is the end,
right? Of course
[Music] Normally, I wouldn't be
able to use it until the final version of the game, a high-headed spell, a series of spells,
Breathing, if it's an attack that's currently at its highest level, it would be a
shame. If the
opponent I'm sorry for wasn't me, it's
decided now.  I wonder how he dodged it by
teleporting, but he reacted in that instant, and
even his speed was a monster.In any case, Rei, that's
a little too much.No matter
how much magic water reduction barrier he
says, if the current one had hit him directly, he wouldn't have been injured.  But hey, it's me, so I
showed you something interesting, so maybe I should
get serious, or something bad will come.
Once again, I
can't breathe, don't listen,
but this is the end.
[Music]
Dominator 4-attribute magic The
strongest and worst attack that controls all magical power in the Dominator range and causes it to run out of control.The
ultimate weapon in magic versus magic.